حذر رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتز من
ضرر حقيقي ووشيك سيصيب الجيش في حال تمرير
مشروع التغييرات القضائيه التي طرحتها
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو واكد هاليزي انه
اذا لم يكن الجيش قويا ومتماسكا فان
اسرائيل لن تتمكن من الوجود كدوله مشيرا
بذلك الى اتساع العصيان داخل المؤسسه
العسكريه رفضا لتلك التغييرات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دلالات التحذير الذي اطلقه رئيس اركان
الجيش الاسرائيلي بشان بقاء الدوله ووحده
جيشها بسبب التغييرات القضائيه واتساع
عصيان الاوامر العسكريه والاحتجاجات في
الشارع رفضا لها
[موسيقى]
الى اي مدى ينصت نتنياهو لتلك التحذيرات
القادمه من داخل حكومته ومن خارجها وكيف
ستتعامل حكومته مع تصاعد الاحتجاج
والاسيان للاوامر داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
وكيف تنظر واشنطن لهذه الازمه في ضوء
التحذيرات القادمه من اوساط اليسار
اليهودي في الولايات المتحده التي تحذر من
انهيار الدوله الاسرائيليه ومن الخطر الذي
يتهدد وجودها
[موسيقى]
لم يعد الامر يقبل التاجيل فيما يبدو لذلك
طلب رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هيلتي
هاليزي مقابله عاجله مع نتنياهو مقابله
محورها الاساس تداعيات تفاقم ظاهره
العصيان داخل المؤسسه العسكريه رفضا
للتغييرات القضائيه هاليزي وفي محاوله
لانقاذ الموقف دعا جنود الاحتياط للعوده
الى الخدمه لان اوان الاصلاح لم يفوت بعد
من وجهه نظره زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
يا ايرلبيد جدد انتقاداته للحكومه قائلا
ان حكومه نتنياهو اعلنت حرب استنزاف ضد
مواطنيها بينما ابواب الرئاسه مفتوحه
لعوده الحوار ومنع الكارثه في اشاره الى
دعوه الرئيس هرتزوك للحوار وبينما تراوح
الازمه مكانها بل وتتعقد اكثر اي رؤساء
سابقون لهيئه اركان الجيش وجهاز الموساد
والشباك ايدوا اعلان عشره الاف من قوات
الاحتياط امتناعهم عن التطوع في الخدمه
العسكريه الاحتياطيه
مسؤولون في الاجهزه الامنيه حذروا من انما
تقوم به حكومه نتنياهو شديد الخطوره على
النسيج الاجتماعي في اسرائيل
ويتصاعد الرفض داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
للتغييرات القضائيه حيث اعلن اكثر من 100
ضابط احتياط في القياده الشماليه توقفهم
عن الخدمه وعلق اكثر من 100 مجند تطوعه في
وحده لوتر المختصه في مكافحه الارهاب
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الناصره
الدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل
للدراسات الاجتماعيه والتطبيقيه والخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن معنا
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه مرحبا بكما
وسؤالنا للدكتور مهند مصطفى دكتور
التحذيرات الصادره من زعماء المعارضه
بخصوص ان اسرائيل يمكن ان تكون على اعتاب
حرب اهليه يمكن ان ينظر اليها على انها من
قبيل مبالغات الساسه المنافسين لتنياهو
ويمكن ان لا تؤخذ على محمل الجد لكن
التحذير هذه المره قادم من رجل محترف
عسكري محترف ورئيس الاركان الذي يتحدث عن
تماسك الدوله برمتها وانها لن تستطيع
الصمود اذا لم يكن الجيش متماسكا الى اي
مدن كلابه يقبل
التقييم من حيث انه فيه مبالغه اولى في
تقديرك
لا ليس فيه ولا اي مبالغه لانه الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو عمليا كان عاكسه للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي هو مؤسسه
استطاعت ان تذيب كل الفروقات الطبقيه
والاجتماعيه والاثنيه في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وان توحدها في داخل الجيش
الجيش الاسرائيلي قوته انه كان يعتبر جيش
الشعب واي اختلال واي انتهاك او اهتراء
لمفهوم جيش الشعب في ذلك يدعف الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي هو جيش ايضا
يعتمد على قوات الاحتياط وبالذات على قوات
الاحتياط التوعيه وخصوصا في الوحدات
النخباويه في داخل جيش الاسرائيلي وبالذات
سلاح الجو الان الجيش الاسرائيلي
دخل الى هذا النقاش السياسي في داخل
اسرائيل وبالذات في قطاع الطيران وفي قطاع
الوحدات النخباويه التي تنتمي من الناحيه
الاجتماعيه والط الطبقيه الى الطبقات
الاجتماعيه التي تعارض هذه التغييرات
الدستوريه وبالذات القطاعات الاجتماعيه
القادمه من مركز الدوله تنتمي اكثر الى
الطبقه الاشكنازيه او الى الطبقات
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه الراقيه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الذين يدخلون عاده الى سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي وايضا الى نخب عسكريه
اخرى الدخول السياسه الى داخل الجيش وهذا
الخلاف في داخل جيش وايضا هنالك خلاف بين
الوحدات المختلفه داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
يهدد تماسك الجيش الاسرائيلي وبالاساس
يهدد مفهوم الجيش الاسرائيلي على انه جيش
الشعب اسرائيل منظمتها الامنيه قائمه على
وحده الجيش الاسرائيلي وان المؤسسه
العسكريه رغم الخلافات الكبيره جدا
والعميقه في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي تبقى
هذه الخلافات على مدار التاريخ اسرائيل
خارج الجيش الان التغييرات الدستوريه
الحاليه عمليا ادخلت الجيش الاسرائيلي الى
هذا الخلاف ومزقته من الداخل وادت الى
تاكل التكتل الداخلي الذي يعتبر دوت الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه جيش يتجاوز كل الخلافات
السياسيه والايدولوجيه والطبقيه
والاجتماعيه الموجوده في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ما حدث الان هو حدث غير مسبوق
في تاريخ اسرائيل هذا حدث غير مسبوق في
التاريخ اسرائيل ان هذا النقاش وهذا
الصراع دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي ادى الى
اعلان مئات من الضباط الاسرائيليين
وبالذات في الوحدات الهامه جدا في داخل
جيش مثل سلاح الطيران مثل وحده
الاستخبارات
ثمانيه 200 ووحدات كوماندوز اخرى الذين
اعلنوا انهم لن يخدموا في الجيش اذا تم تم
هذا البند في التغييرات الدستوريه الذي
يعتبر
بند يهدد استقلاليه السلطه القضائيه في
اسرائيل وهو بند المعقوليه ولذلك هذا
التاكل في وحده الجيش في مفهوم كجيش الشعب
هو عمليا تهديد ابن قومي اسرائيلي لانه
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي قائم بالاساس على
الحفاظ على هذا الجيش الذي كان يعتبر بقره
مق الى الان هذا الجيش لم يعد بقى مقدسه
في اسرائيل ولذلك اختلال التكتل الداخلي
اختلال التعادل الداخلي الصراع في داخل
جيش بين وحداته الصراع في داخل جيش بين
مواقف سياسيه مختلفه سيؤدي الى اضعاف
الجيش هنالك في تقديرات اسرائيليه تقول
الان انه بسبب رفض مئات الضباط في سلاح
الطيران عمليا الان سلاح الطيران
الاسرائيلي اصيب في حاله شلل وعدم جهوزيه
لاي تحدي امني او عسكري قادم في داخل
اسرائيل هذا يعتبر بالنسبه لقاعده هيئه
الاركان تهديدا مباشرا وعميقا للامن
القومي الاسرائيلي وهو تهديد وهو تنبيه
وتحذير جدي وحقيقي الذي يواجه الان المؤسس
العسكريه الاسرائيليه دكتور خليل الى اي
مدن ينسجم هذا التحذير الذي اطلقه رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي مع بواعث واشارات
القلق الصادره من واشنطن اتجاه الازمه في
اسرائيل
ولا مساء الخير استاذ محمود لك وتحيه لك
وللدكتور مهند المشاهدين ينسجم الى حد
بعيد وكما تفضل دكتور مهند وفصل في الامر
نحن ازاء اعمق واخطر ازمه سياسات تمر بها
اسرائيل منذ انشائيه قبل 75 عام هذا ليس
كلامي ولا كلام
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق يتحدث قبل خمسه
شهور قال نحن ازاء ازمه تهدد بانقسام
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتفككه وقيام حرب
اهليه وبالتالي هناك
تحذيرات تاتي من قبل راس الدوله في
اسرائيل تتناغم معها بشكل او باخر الموقف
الامريكيه الرئيس الامريكي الحالي بايدن
تحدث قبل فتره قليله مع السنين وقال نحن
ازاء واحده من اكثر الحكومات الاسرائيليه
تطرفا نحن اذا لازم استاذ محمود نحن ازمه
سياسيه تقوم او جهه نتيجه لوجود صفقه
سياسيه بين نتنياهو من جهه الذي كان يحاول
عوده السلطه بعد خروجه منها قبل عام ونصف
من الان كي يستمر فيه اكثر وقت ممكن
بالتحالف مع قوى اليمير مضطر في الفاشل
الذي لديه اجنده تقوم على تهيئه الاجواء
من اجل قضم المزيد من الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وجزء رئيس المتعلق بما يسمى بتعدلات قانون
السلطه القضائيه والحد من المعقوليه يتعلق
بالاساس باطلاق يد المستوطنين في بناء
مستوطنات كثيره في الضفه الغربيه بضفه
الماضي هو السماح ببناء 7000 وحده اساطنيه
او 7,000 واحده سكنيه جديده داخل مستويات
الموجوده حاليا وبالتالي حتى هذه اللحظه
موقف رافض لحد بعيد جزء منهم طلاقا مما
يراه تقويضا للاسر المشتركه ما بين
الدولتين الامريكيه والاستراليه فيما
يتعلق بالديمقراطيه وبالتالي عندما يتم
الحد من صلاحيات المحكمه العليا هذا يعني
نقص وتراجع للسلطات والسلطات كما هو موجود
في الحاله الامريكيه والامر جاء ايضا على
لسان واحد من اهم رموز الصحافه الامريكيه
والمقرب البيت الابيض وتوماس فريدمان الذي
التقى الاسبوع الماضي ببايدن ولم يبدو
بايدن ارسل بعض الرسائل من خلال
مقاله قبل يومين تتحدث فيها عن
تعديلات القضائيه ومحاوله التوصل اكبر قدر
من الاجماع والا سيكون هناك تعاقب وخيمه
على العلاقات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه قد
تصل الى عقود قادمه وبالتالي هناك كما
يخاف امريكيه سواء من الاداره الامريكيه
سواء من خلال اليسار اليسار الامريكي الذي
يعتبر
لكنه يرى ايضا هذه الازمه تؤثر على موقفه
الداخلي وبالتالي هناك حاجه لوجود اجماع
اسرائيل
فيما يتعلق هذه التعديلات
دكتور مهند في الاثناء يلتقي الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتزوك برئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو وسيبحث لاحقا مع زعيم
المعارضه مساله التغييرات القضائيه هل
ينجح في تقديرك في احتواء هذه الازمه هل
يلين موقف نتنياهو بعض الشيء او يلين موقف
زعماء المعارضه المتشدد والمتصلب ازاء هذه
التعديلات ايضا بعض الشيء
دعني اقول انه الامل في التوصل الى توافق
حول التغييرات الدستوريه الان هو ضعيف جدا
اولا هناك كان في تجربه سابقه التي فيها
استضاف رئيس الدوله
كل الاطراف من اجل التوصل الى التوافق حول
التغيرات الدستوريه وهذا النقاش
والمباحثات في بيت رئيس استمرت اشهر كامله
ولم تفضي الى شيء بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك
نتنياهو موجود في مازق سياسي حقيقي المازق
السياسي يتمثل في انه من جهه لا يستطيع
الان ان يتراجع عن تغيير هذا البند الحديث
الان هو عن بند واحد في التغيرات
الدستوريه ولذلك التراجع عنه سوف يؤدي الى
تاكل شعبيته بشكل كبير جدا في صفوف اليمين
الاسرائيلي قواعد اليمين الاسرائيلي تؤيد
هذه التغييرات وهي اعطت نتنياهو فرصه
ثانيه من اجل ان يقوم بهذه التغييرات يعني
في المره الاولى عندما ذهب نتنياهو الى
التغييرات كانت التغييرات شامله وواسعه
وشمله كل المجالات الان نتنياهو ذاهب الى
تغيير في بند واحد ولكنه بند بالنسبه
للمؤسسه القضائيه هو بند خطير جدا ولكن
القواعد اليمنيه تقول لنا نتنياهو انه على
الاقل هذا البند عليك ان تقوم باكراره
واذا نتنياهو تراجع عن هذا البند او انه
تخاذل او انه خضع الى ضغوطات المعارضه
الاسرائيليه والى الضغوطات الاحتجاج ومن
ذلك هذه قد يؤدي الى سقوط الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولذلك نتنياهو في مازق حقيقي
جدا من جهه هو لا يريد اسقاط حكومته ومن
جهه ثانيه هو يعلم انه اذا استمر في هذا
التغيير الدستوري قد يؤدي الى ازمه حقيقيه
على المستوى المجتمع الاسرائيلي عموما
وعلى المستوى الجيش خصوصا الان هنالك في
ضغوطات على نتنياهو في اخر لحظه يعني يجب
ان نذكر انه اقرار هذا البند سيتم يوم غد
ولذلك في هذا المساء هنالك في ضغوطات
كبيره جدا على نتنياهو الان تدخل الى
المعركه او الى ساحه الصراع لنقابه العم
في اسرائيل التي هددت انها سوف تضرب وسوف
تشل القطاع الاقتصادي في داخل اسرائيل
هنالك ضغط من من رئيس الاسرائيلي طبعا من
قاده الاجهزه العسكريه والامنيه
والاستخباطيه على تنياهو وذلك ضغط في داخل
الكود نفسه من اطراف معينه في داخل الكود
مثل وزير الدفاع يقف قلند الذي يعلم خطوره
هذا التغيير على الجيش الاسرائيلي ولذلك
ايضا يضغط على تنياهو من اجل تاجيل
التصويت على هذا البند انا في التصور الان
في مازق سياسي سوف يميل بتصوري الى انه
سوف يطرح معادله انه اعطوني ان اكرر هذا
البند حاليا لكي احافظ على حكومتي واي
تغيير مستقبل سوف يكون سوف يعني
ايضا
المتابع لهذه الازمه من خارج اسرائيل قد
يجد غرابه بعض الشيء في هذا الموقف
المتصلب في معارضه هذه التغييرات القضائيه
يعني في نهايه المطاف لا تنتهك ايا من
القوانين الاساس التي تعمل بها اسرائيل
بدلا من الدستور لانه اسرائيل ليست لها
ليس لها دستور
وايضا في نهايه المطاف الذي يدفع باتجاه
هذه التغييرات حكومه منتخبه ائتلاف منتخب
ويملك الاغلبيه في الكنيست يعني الخلاف
بالاساس هو خلاف سياسيه وليس خلاف قانوني
ولا دستوري
لا يعني الخلاف هو طبعا يعني تقاطعت فيه
الكثير من العوامل السياسي ايديولوجي ولكن
ايضا قضائي يعني اذا اخذنا على سبيل
المثال هذا البند تحديدا هو بند المعقوليه
اسرائيل هي دوله نظام سياسي بدون دستور
وفيها فقط حارس واحد على القوانين الاساس
التي هي قوانين دستوريه في اسرائيل الحارس
الوحيد على هذه القوانين هو المحكمه
العليا في اسرائيل الان قانون المعقوليه
هو جاء من اجل ان يعطي المحكمه العليا
صلاحيات من اجل الغاء قرارات او اجراءات
تقوم بها الحكومه التي تعتبر في نظر
المحكمه اجراءات متطرفه وتهدد الكثير من
القيم مثل المستواه مثل العداله ومثل ومثل
حقوق الانسان الى ذلك الغاء هذا البند بند
المعقوليه هو عمليا يعطي الحكومه الحريه
الكامله في ان تتخذ اي قرار اجرائي او
تنظيمي دون ان يكون المحكمه العليا اي
صلاحيه في الغاء هذا القرار هذا عمليا هو
يعطي قوه كبيره جدا للسلطه التنفيذيه في
اسرائيل في ظل نظام سياسي ليس فيه دستور
في ظل نظام سياسي ليس فيه ثقافي دمقراطيه
والحارس الوحيد على البنيه الدستوريه في
اسرائيل هي المحكمه العليا طبعا ان يتقاطع
في ذلك ايضا عوامل سياسيه وايدولوجيه
العامل السياسي الاساسي من يحكم الان
اسرائيل ونريد ان يحدث هذه التغييرات هم
هم من الشرائح المتدينه المتطرفه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي والشرائح العلمانيه
الليبراليه لا تريد من هذه الشرائع ان
تغير الدوله التي اقاموها في عام 1948
يريدون ان تبقى الدوله كما هي ولنسمحوا
لهؤلاء من ان يغيروا هذا النظام الدستوري
والسياسي دكتور خليل يعني نتنياهو له
تاريخ طويل في التعامل بفضاضه وتجاهل
نصائح حلفائه الغربيين ولعلك تذكر ما كان
يقول عنه ساركوزي مثلا وكذلك مواقفه من
براك اوباما والاراء المتبادله بينهما الى
اي مدن يمكن ان يبلغ حدود التاثير الذي
يمكن ان يمثله الرئيس جو بايدن
والحلفاء الغربيون عموما على قرار نتنياهو
خلال هذه اللحظات الاخيره قبيل اقرار
التغييرات القضائيه
انا اعتقد التاثير الامريكي بشكل عام خاصه
بعض المؤشرات او المؤشر انه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يحدث اتصال تليفوني
بينعلق كما حدث مثلا في مارس الموضع عندما
تحدث معه بشكل قوي وفضلوا بشكل فوري يتم
وقف التعديلات حتى يتم التواصل لنعمه
الاتفاق او نوع من الاجماع حولها بين اكبر
قدر من اطياف في المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
المره الوضع مختلف حتى هذه اللحظه ليس
هناك على قال اتصلونا بين الطرفين فقط
وهذا مؤشر اخر ايضا يقام بتمرير رسائل من
خلال طرف ثالث وهو صحفي توماس وهذا يعتبر
مؤشر ضعف او عدم رغبه في بايدن بالضغط على
نتناول السبب مهم جدا والمتعلق نحن نحن
على ابواب الحمل الانتخابيه القادمه التي
تبدا في العامل القادم وبالتالي ليس هناك
او ليس هنا من مصلحه بيضه ان يقوم
باستفزاز بايدل استفزاز اللوجو الاسرائيلي
الموجود في امريكا بما قد يؤثر سلبا على
الانتخابات القادمه الامر الثالث انه
راينا على مدار الفتره الماضيه هناك دعم
شبه كامل من امريكا لاسرائيل
عمليه اجتياح الاسرائيلي لمدينه مخيم
جنينه وبالتالي هناك دعم امريكي واضح جدا
لهذه الحكومه رغم اختلافها معها فيما
يتعلق بوجود عناصر مطرفه وبالتالي التعويل
على وجود ضغط امريكي قوي فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه الدفع بنتنياهو
لعدم تامر هذه التعديلات قد يكون ضعيفه قد
يكون مخرج من هذه الازمه امكانيه تجميد
النقاش حول هذه المساله ما يحدث الان نحن
ايذاء محاوله للدفع في اخر لحظه في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي الذي هو ياخذ اجازه
بعد اقل من اسبوع من الان كما حوالي
للمتطرف بدفع هذه المساله كي يتم الانتهاء
منها النقاد ربما يكون مخرج لمتانياهو
لانه فعلا فيما
انه يقوم بتاجيل هذه المناقشات وقد ياتي
طبعا بالسلب عليه انه قد يكون يعني قد
يؤدي الى نوع من التفكك في حكومات
الائتلاف التي جاءت بالاساس من اجل تمرير
هذه الاجنه المتطرفه وبالتالي قد يكون
ربما الضغط الامريكي متعلق بامكانيه تاجيل
تمير هذه التعديلات حتى يتم وجود نقاش
حوله على كانه ايضا غير مضمون على قد هذه
اللحظه وبالتالي امكانيه وجود ضغط امريكي
على نتنياهو من اجل وقف هذه المساله في
ظني امر غير دقيق
شايفين الكرام بينما تستمر الازمه
السياسيه في اسرائيل على واقع رفض حزب
اللكود مقترحه نقابه العمال الهيستروت
لحلها لا تظهر تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الاخيره اي
بوادر للتراجع ففي اخر ما ادلى به من
مواقف قال نواصل جهودنا لتمرير التشريعات
بالتوافق العام واضاف غدا صباحا ساكون الى
جانب زملائي في الكنيست دكتور مهند كيف
نفهم مساله التوافق العام او حديث نتنياهو
عن التوافق العام وعزمه بشكل اكيد على ان
يكون الى جانب زملائي في الكنيست والتحذير
التام من انه من سيمتنع عن التصويت حتى لن
يرفض من سيمتنع عن التصويت سيطرد فورا من
الحزب كيف نفهم هذا وذاك
نعم
نعم هذا هي استراتيجيه نتنياهو
الاستراتيجيه تقوم على انه يريد حاليا ان
يصوت غدا على هذا البند العيني وهو بند
المعقوليه من اجل ان يؤذي اعضاء الائتلاف
الحكومي ويحافظ على حكومته لانه اذا تراجع
عن هذا البند حكومته في خطر ان تسقط ولكن
في نفس الوقت هو يعني يعد الجميع يعني وعد
رئيس الدوله ووعد كل اطراف السياسه في
اسرائيل ان اي تغيير مستقبل سوف يكون سوف
يحدث من خلال التوافق طبعا المشكله ان
هنالك ليس
وجود اي ثقه بلا ثنياهو يعني المعارضه
الاسرائيليه والاحتجاج في اسرائيل لا يثق
في نتنياهو بتاتا لانه معروفه انه مخادع
وانه كذاب وانه يفي وانه لا يلتزم بوعوده
ولذلك نتنياهو يريد غدا ان يجتاز هذه
الازمه فقط على المستوى السياسي الداخلي
معنى فقط على مستوى الحفاظ على حكومته وهو
يعول ان اجازه الصيف وخروج الكنيست
الاجازه الصيفيه سيستطيع من خلالها ان
يتجاوز كل الازمه السياسيه والعسكريه
الموجوده في اسرائيل ولكن حلقه الاحتجاج
مستمره وايضا مصيره على ان تستمر في
احتجاجها حتى بعد اقرار بند المعقوليه
ولكن طبعا كل شيء وارد من الان حتى صباح
الغد ان يهين نتنياهو او ان يكون بنفسه
بذاته بدون اي مباحثات او اي توافق ان
يقوم بتعديل بند المعقوليه ويطرح صيغه
قانون اكثر معتدله ولكن هذا ايضا احتمال
ضعيف جدا لانه عليه ضغط كبير جدا من اعضاء
الائتلاف الحكومي من اجل ان يصوت على هذا
البنك كما تم الاختصار عليه
الذهاب يعني اذا ما ركن الى هذا الخيار ما
احتمالات انهيار الائتلاف الحكومي والذهاب
الى انتخابات مبكره مجددا
اختصرت شديد لو تكرمت يعني احتمال
احتمال كبير جدا وبالذات ان هنالك في
اطراف بالذات حزب عظمه يهوديه برئاسه
ينتظر اي مؤشره من اجل الخروج من الحكومه
لانه يعني كان فاشلا في هذه الحكومه
وينتظر اي سبب واي زريعه لكي يخرج من
الحكومه وقد هد بيض انه في حاله لم يتم
اكرار هذا البند فهو سوف يخرج بحكومه وهذا
معناه الحكومه
دكتور خليل هناك تقيمان لما يحدث في
اسرائيل مع كل هذه الحشود بمئات الالاف
الموجوده في الشوارع للاحتجاج والتمرد
داخل الجيش وما الى ذلك مما عرضناه هناك
من ينظر لما يحدث في اسرائيل على انه
علامه على هشاشه اسرائيل كدوله وتفككها
وقبليه انهيارها وكذلك هناك من يقيمه على
انها علامه عافيه بدليل قوه المجتمع
المدني الذي يقف
بهذه القوه لما يرونه مخلا باسس الدوله
الى اي الاحتملين تميل
يعني هي المساله مش في هذه الباصات استاذ
محمود يعني نحن ازمه سياسيه حقيقيه لديها
اتداعيات متعلقه بوحده الجيش الاسرائيلي
كما يعني جاء قبل قليل يمثل منطقه صهر
مختلف الاثنيات والعرقيات الموجوده في
اسرائيل والخلفات الايدولوجيه والطبقيه
والاجتماعيه لكن ايضا هناك ازمه سياسيه
حقيقيه موجوده في اسرائيل جزء منه او جزء
من الدعايه الديمقرا هناك مساحه للتعبير
وان هناك امكانيه تحدي اي قرارات سياسيه
من خلال التظاهرات في الشعر من خلال
التعبئه لكن ايضا تداعياتها العسكريه
والامنيه كبيره جدا خطر بيتكلم على دوله
جزر رئيس من عقيدتها متعلق بالامن وجزء
منه متعلق
بالوحده الداخليه فيما تتعلق مواجهه
الاقطار الخارجيه وما اخشاه هذه اللحظه
انه حتى يتم الهروب من هذه الازمه كما حدث
قبل شهور قليله هو القفز للامام باتجاه
افتعال ازمات مع اطراف اخرى تحديدا فيما
يتعلق بامكانيه شن عمليات عسكريه اخرى
سواء كان في الضفه الغربيه سواء كانت
بالتغذى سواء كان في القدس في القدس
الشرقيه وبالتالي
هذه الازمه قد تبدو فعليا ازمه دليل صحه
على قوه الصليب الديمقراطيه لكن تمثل خطر
ياتي من خلال كما قلت قبل قليل المحالين
سياسيين يعني امثالنا جاء من خلال راس
الدوله في اسرائيل جاء اليوم من خلال رئيس
الاركان الاسلام على انه احد التداعيات
الخطيه لهذه الازمه المتعلق بامكانيه تفكك
الاسرائيلي الذي يعتبر هو اخر حصن امان
الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق دوله اسرائيل
الدكتور خليل العداني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه كان معنا
واشنطن واشكر كذلك ضيفنا من النصر الدكتور
مهند مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
الاجتماعيه التطبيقيه والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائي ليه الى هناك تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج من وراء الخبر دمتم في امان
الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]